i wrote the perfect song for this
perfect cast
really yeah
is
guess i'll just close my eyes
sorry we got
whoa what happened guys whoa
oh man wow were you really playing that
mouth whistle
oh yeah
uh how did this happen um so okay before
we get into it
all right so we had a little outbreak
in the studio and it sucks because it
happened you know
we're pretty far into this and it
happened legit
on the day that everyone got vaccinated
yep it couldn't be funny it couldn't be
more ironic timing
like everyone went out and got
vaccinated and then
like people were like is this just the
symptoms or
and then you know over the course of the
last week
it's just been like everyone's been
getting tested constantly and it's just
been like
half negatives half positives so it's
been rough
um nick i mean you've had it kind of the
worst
i think i was i think i might have been
the super spreader yeah
or zero in the office right yeah so
i think it was monday when we were
filming the linus tech tips video
that because it seems like everyone who
is in that room
got it as well so yeah we're in an
enclosed space
filming all day long and i just remember
on monday i'm like
man i should turn the ac up it's kind of
hot in here now i know why
that felt like that but yeah i don't
know man it's uh
i feel like we we've just been like
neoing
these bullets just dodging them for like
a year and a half
yeah i mean like everybody has you know
yeah
especially when you're trying to film
when you're trying to get together and
film
anything like you know there's 15 people
like you know it's it
we and to everyone's credit like
everyone's been doing a
very good job of of being conscious
of it um but i just think like you know
there's been enough cases at this point
it's it's been
out there enough like you know it's it's
like any illness like you're bound to
come into contact with it at some point
and it's just that was our time
yeah yeah yeah i still fortunate
i have no idea how i didn't get it i
don't i mean maybe you have
maybe of natural antibodies some people
do yeah
yeah or uh maybe it's a little bit of
this
did you did you did you get the bag
there's a vaccine for you
yeah so i was i was in the car with uh
with peter griffin and daniel
and we were all like super hyped about
it you know like oh we just got the
vaccine
oh hell yeah we're in the clear now you
know
and was that last monday or was that
what was that like last year that was on
mid last
thursday i think that was uh yeah we
went on thursday yeah so we're about a
week in
of taking the vaccine yeah and griffin
got it
uh and then daniel me and peter are
still testing negative so
it's like and wren yeah and and wren
yeah
which is odd because he was in the room
with us filming peter
but he got vaccinated earlier
than everyone else so it could have been
that he
just didn't throw symptoms but he did
get tested
didn't he so he said i believe he did
because you can still get rona if you
have a vaccine
right you just don't get symptoms as bad
yeah and i thought it was more like you
you pass it on less too like you're not
you're not really paying it on
yeah and i didn't get tested positive
until freaking yesterday and which is
crazy
just for the record it's like seven days
that's a full week after i started
exhibiting symptoms
so that's crazy i mean when they say it
takes 10 days to like gestate
i mean that's apparently true that's a
key example right there
yeah um very very unless i picked it up
from
like i guess if i maybe i missed it on
the monday session but then i got it
from nico on the thursday session
could have been so right now at this
point i know more people who have gotten
it than have not
oh yeah in my close in my close group of
friends and stuff like do you have it i
did not
but uh all of my neighbors did
well and uh and then now
half of the studio has um so
that you know and then all the black
rifle guys
pretty much did that's like like two
like two months ago
yeah yeah um so yeah we're up to five
now in the studio
five total yep wow
what's weird is that sometimes like
people who live together
one person will get it and the other
person won't even though they were like
in the same circumstances and
um yeah but i guess that's kind of like
you know
like sometimes that happens with other
illnesses too um
so but it seems like given the
high rate of contagiousness that that
wouldn't be the case but
yeah it definitely is very contagious
um so nick and christian how are you
guys feeling
let's see so i started getting symptoms
on
tuesday i think um even though i
was i guess spreading it on monday
started feeling like [ __ ] on tuesday
peaked like
wednesday thursday with a fever
um thursday i lost my taste my smell
still haven't gotten it back
and uh but you know it's just been a
slow getting better since then
you know every day i feel better but
still just overall like
sick feeling this uh you know but
honestly i've had worse flus
before i mean my fever was not that high
comparatively
um and you know i felt much worse
it's kind of like a cold without the
actual congestion
one of the worst parts was the sinus
pain and i've heard this from a couple
other people was like
it feels like there's something stuck up
in your sinus and it gives you kind of
that headache
behind your eyes and that happened right
as i lost my smell
and my taste so it's probably correlated
but uh that went away after a couple
days so
this week it's just been waking up every
day feeling a little bit better
yeah and uh hopefully it continues what
have you been doing just getting rest
and like drinking water and all the
normal
stuff all i do is hydrate literally i
just
all i do is hydrate all that no really i
mean that's
you know the appetite's been so so
especially when you can't taste or smell
so
yeah um kind of you know it's like
barbra who was it barbarossa or was it
davey jones from pirates of the
caribbean he's like yeah yeah yeah
wine turns yeah wine and food turns to
ash in your
mouth yeah so that's what it's like but
um
to taste nothing to feel nothing dude
exactly it's been a little bit of like
uh cabin fever going on though trying to
get out and do a walk every day trying
to
play some guitar every day what what
have you been doing for food sustenance
throughout all this
amazon fresh man yeah sorry to uh plug
bezos here
i mean it's convenient man thirty three
thousand dollars three
thirty three hundred dollar stock price
geez
that's crazy i've just been doing that
and uh cooking
cooking a lot so good yeah eating a lot
of citrus
yeah i have a completely different
experience i mean i could i wasn't
feeling
anything at all i was like kind of like
you know feeling pretty good about
because everyone was rolling in with the
negatives again i think i
i dodged a bullet i feel pretty healthy
i like even kept working out over the
weekend
um and then it was just like went to bed
on monday night and i just kind of had
the sweats
and woke up on tuesday and it just felt
like uh
fatigued and like i guess my bones just
kind of felt achy but i like
that was kind of it but i was just like
this is kind of weird so that's when i
went and got tested and then it
came back positive so um i mean but
otherwise like yeah
taste and smell still intact just a
little kind of like
tired and sore kind of thing and there's
like a cough but i feel like that's like
totally mental like i'm only coughing
when i think about it
it's not like you know it's totally like
i'm forcing it
exactly it's it's not like it like you
get that tickle or like the phlegm
coming it's just like
yeah exactly like i don't know i'm just
kind of like uh
i need to cough like i just it's weird
but otherwise so far like
it's like a dry cough feel healthy it's
just yeah at the night it's a little
sweaty and
i don't know all right well since we're
all sharing our symptoms
over here uh there there was actually
some craziness
just getting the vaccine it was it was
like a lot
like more intense than i thought it was
gonna be which one did you get
uh we got the the j and j bill johnson
pre
you got that pre-banned j and j yeah
yeah the previous yeah yeah
yeah that's the real spicy stuff that's
like the four loko when it first came
right
exactly i might die i might not i don't
know we'll find out
now do you guys think it's like right
that they banned the johnson johnson
vaccine because well they they
pause they pause they're gonna do more
trials
yeah which is fair was it only six
people or
that's what i heard six women got it got
one of them critical one who passed they
were like blood clots or something right
yeah it's um i mean it's a tough call
because you know they're
not that i'm an expert in this i'm just
gonna say like from an outside
perspective the thing that you need to
maintain
is like the integrity of when the fda
says this is good you know
and so i think that is probably more
up in the mind than than like the
the the cost to value or the you know
ratio
of of like what that is because
obviously like
if you lose that integrity you know it's
very very hard to get back
especially in a time like this so that i
mean maybe that's where their heads are
at but i don't know
i don't know enough about it to speak
beyond that honestly
yeah i think there's enough there's
enough options out there that i i don't
think it's a bad thing that they
recalled it and tried
tried to like you know really uh uh get
it working right
um but you got in just in time matt
and i got it just in time yeah and you
said you felt symptoms
like because it seems like most people
in our studio did yeah after they got it
yeah it was it was actually it was
pretty intense because like you say they
say that it's like
one day you know one and done and i was
like oh it's well then it's not gonna
really be that bad
um and i think everyone is affected a
little bit differently by it
but for me it was like body aches
everywhere
um it actually lasted like two days
where i was like pretty pretty shot
um and then uh and then into the weekend
i was still feeling a little bit like
you know drowsy and just just it felt
like
you know everything that you'd feel from
in terms of like body aches and
everything
uh from a flu but without all the other
symptoms like you know there wasn't
there was no congestion or sore throat
or anything like that but okay
um yeah it was pretty intense it wasn't
not uh not my favorite
couple do you feel like a million bucks
now uh no i feel the same
i feel about the same maybe a little bit
more vaccinated than i was before but
that's about it yeah um can are you
supposed to get it i don't know if this
is
this isn't this is our impromptu science
course but i just
are you supposed to get it after you've
had it like nick are you supposed to go
out and get because you didn't get the
vaccine
no i i was literally you were about to
full effect
and then everyone you guys posted that
like that photo of everyone with their
shots i'm like
worst timing and you're not supposed to
get it while you have it that's for sure
no and what i've heard is they want you
to wait i think
what is it 90 days i believe so i've
heard
everywhere from one month from some
people and then i've heard three months
from others 90 days
so you know they say you're supposed to
get it but you're supposed to wait
because i guess you have these
antibodies already you know that that
natty vaccine
so uh yeah i'll probably just wait
a while but it seems like the
information is changing quite frequently
on this
so yeah well you know we're constantly
learning
yeah like think about how much different
the perception of this is
than what it was a year ago yeah like
everything from everything from just
like what we know
to how to deal with it to what you
should and shouldn't do depending on who
you are and and
how you are so yeah
yeah man it's pretty crazy that it's
been over a year
oh yes uh yeah yeah it's been
a hell of a year what is up my sons and
daughters that's right today's episode
is sponsored by storyblocks and i'm here
to tell you
why we use them all the time at corridor
digital and why you should consider
using them too
they're the one-stop shop for all of our
stock asset needs meaning that anytime
we need high quality b-roll
audio assets after effects templates
motion graphics things like that
we head on over to storyblocks.com
corridor cast
and with our unlimited all access plan
we
scour the virtually unlimited library
that they have for
the fresh pieces of b-roll and stock
assets that we need
they are constantly updating that
virtually unlimited library so we almost
never run into the same thing twice and
with that all access plan
it's royalty free so it's easy it's
simple to use
it's high quality and you can use it in
anything so if you're part of a team
they also have enterprise plans which
allow larger teams to get on there
and for all of them to have access if
you guys are interested consider
checking it out that's
storyblocks.comcast all right
see you guys later back to the podcast i
mean
good news is you know especially for
y'all californians out there
uh the the the tale of uh
of cases has significantly dropped off
and
and that's with reopening um you know
same thing
same thing out here in texas it's uh
they continue to drop off and
everything's open so that's
i see that as all good good yeah we
should be all better after it you know
we'll all be antibodies and we'll know
we've had it or you know somebody's
had it and gotten vaccinated so my
biggest concern is like my mother-in-law
you know yeah she lives with us she's in
her 60s like
you know she's doesn't have the greatest
like health record to begin with
she's not like in rough shape or has any
like significant underlying causes but
at the same time i'm just like
you know yeah that's my biggest concern
i think that's the concern the elderly
folks the people yeah pre-existing
conditions you know
i you know is it
is it worth the response lots of people
have you know different opinions on that
but
oh yeah i i know that you know i was
scared from my grandparents and even my
parents you know
it's not like they're crazy old or
anything but still
that guy's like 95.
okay so oh go ahead nick i was gonna say
like
it's really cool that like every like
elderly person i know at least has been
vaccinated so
you know we're getting there yeah i was
finally able to break my grandpa out of
the retirement home just go up with a
crowbar
break them out they wouldn't let anyone
visit they wouldn't let them out
i can't imagine being in there for a
year well because like
yeah that that you know that makes more
sense to me than like
having kids wear masks you know because
like because like you think about an
outbreak in a school with a bunch of
kids
it's like well you know they're kids
they're
the death rate's really low they're
they're not gonna you know and even like
our
age you know we we had this mini
outbreak and it's like
yeah people are feeling pretty pretty
bad but they're not you know no one is
at risk of any further
complications or anything but you
imagine an outbreak at a place like that
like
sun you know right
so uh but anyways what i really wanted
to get to was like
okay when you're
creating uh we're creating we're
releasing five videos a week right now
like what do you do
when like half of the people that you're
working with
like are are just out you know
like how do you how do you bear that
as a as a creator that's really what i
want to talk about today
interesting i feel like we were set up
for a little bit more success
um partly because of circumstance of
like the videos we were releasing this
week
but also because we were we'd like been
working
remotely you know since i mean we had
like two months when we were almost
working remotely
entirely yeah and i feel like that gave
us the tools we need to be able to like
at least keep communication up and stuff
but no i mean it's limiting man and like
you know this linus tech tips video
you'll notice that
the latter part of the video is all shot
from nico's backyard
right um so you have to adapt and find
ways to
tell the story you're trying to tell
just well
from home so yeah the the infrastructure
thing like the digital infrastructure i
mean we have this pretty extensive
discord
server now that didn't exist a year ago
um you know remember when we first
started we were trying to figure out
like okay what platforms should we use
and all that stuff
um thankfully we got we got our internal
servers
figured out via kim and spencer but then
you know
then we started using discord and it's
just it really is adaptable for us
i think like with the video channels the
text channels like the
subgroups all that stuff um that's been
really really nice um and
having that in our back pocket to just
kind of like constantly i mean we're
constantly using it but just to have it
there too
to lean on you know is is a really
really good thing like we
and that's been built up over the course
of the last year you think like if if we
would have got hit early
or you know in other circumstances if
you just have half your people out from
any other
illness like you don't have that you
just have to put everything on pause
you know yeah it's almost yeah yeah it's
almost like we had this pandemic
response already going because like you
said like
we made the discord server because of
the first wave and when we all went into
lockdown and like
that was us adapting and figuring out
how to make that situation work and so
you know now that we're actually getting
hit by it it's like a hybrid of it
because
you know some people can go in and do it
but like we still had that
infrastructure like ready to go so it's
super helpful it i didn't feel like we
had to you know delay too much or
change too much up this week at least
because we had that
it also it created like a kind of a
stepping stone
for jake for you to be able to work
remotely and make that like that was
only possible really
through discord oh yeah yeah for you to
be able to just like
you know pick a virtual jake popping up
on my computer
yeah egg yeah it made it feel like you
were still in the studio in a lot of
ways and that's like that was super
important
yeah yeah that that was um
i think like critical that's why
whenever i'm talking about like my
experience of like now working remotely
all the time
or 90 of the time that i always tell
people like
that that lockdown was a blessing in
disguise for us
because it allowed us to come up with
that and then for us to carry that over
when i moved
and uh yeah it's i mean honestly it's
been pretty smooth
um all things considered uh
for for how much you know like
and like nick you know the other day you
and sam and i
were filming something together
even though you guys were in la and i
was out here
i had you on discord and i had my camera
set up right here
and you guys were walking me through
like the scene we were
because how how would we been able to do
that otherwise it would have
because it's such a it's such an
interactive the little lower thirds guys
say i'm popping yeah for the uh
functional filmmaking for any context
like they were literally able to direct
you while being in completely different
you know areas
right you could have you could have
written me an email
trying to try these things or you could
have called me but it
like you know being able to visually see
me and then see me do the takes
and then like give your give your
natural just direct response to it is so
much better than than doing doing things
other ways so
yeah i think the first takeaway is like
you know for
people out there that are kind of
wondering like well how how do
how do we get through situations like
this the first and foremost thing is
don't wait to have your infrastructure
in place
you know um and now well
ours sort of occurred serendipitously we
we did have slack and we were
transitioning like
to a more digital method of
communication
prior to the lockdowns last year but
that i'd obviously sped it up but i
guess you know saying like don't wait
because
you want those infrastructures in place
so that when you do have a rainy day
you have something to to fall back on
and call back on that
that's already there and that's already
functioning um
so that's been i think something i've
been thinking about
and i i think we'll see lasting impacts
in our workflow i mean we already have
we
we use discord every single day i mean
i communicate with people when i'm in
the studio with people
over discord because it's easier than
going and searching
you know it's now like the studio is
like huge and sometimes
you lose people so it just ping them on
discord so
yeah i mean that imagining a time when
we didn't have discord now is kind of
weird
like i'm trying to think like how did we
shop thumbnails and like how did we like
oh yeah dude no you guys were just like
i remember when i when i first started
working here like the the whole thing
was just on like a freaking
a white board you guys are all just
standing around like mad scientists
like trying to concoct thumbnails yeah
like yeah
yeah yeah what if you did this sure and
like a beautiful mind
like just yeah it was man and we'd stand
around and critique each other
and like critique the the framing with
these janky hand-drawn
draw erase board images yeah yeah like
hieroglyphics you'd have to like walk
over to griffin's desk where he can just
upload like hey here's a version what do
you guys think and it's like
so much more efficient it's yeah and
quite frankly it was a little
distracting sometimes because you all
would get into arguments about it and
stuff and i'd just be here trying to
edit
oh yeah yeah got a little a little rowdy
and then and then we would constantly
reference google trends yeah
yeah still do google trends was our
was our i mean it still is yeah it's our
like i don't know if you all invest out
there but like that the idea of
having google trends is basically the
equivalent of our stock price
checker where we go in and we check the
tr the history of the usage of terms
over time
to see if they're commonly used and
relevant compared to other terms it's
actually a really useful tool
very if you're trying to figure out how
to max out your uh
your title like i guess beef it up
how how popular how well it's gonna
perform google trend it you know like
is it we made a new scorpion king or
we built a new scorpion king hmm i can't
decide go to google trends
yeah it'll let you know you know um
actually mentions that in his in as one
of his techniques
in his functional filmmaking episode
yeah which comes out next week plug
shameless plug shameless um yeah
wait did a sam's episode drop today uh i
dropped i dropped it last night hey
um dude what's going on out there is
there an emergency
freaking i live in downtown l.a man it's
all happening all the time
okay you probably got a helicopter you
got probably got a helicopter right
outside of your window man probably
christian's on the 100th floor of some
skyrise down there now here's all the
sounds
downtown sound like the 800th floor
that hour is living dude how tall is
that building christian
i don't know if he can hear us he might
have stepped away
yeah he did he went to go ask them he's
like hey can you pipe down please
i'm filming over here don't fly please
come on
how tall is that building you're in uh
okay i'm on the 29th okay so yeah
it's very high i've never i'm not scared
of heights but
i definitely don't put myself
voluntarily into high situations like
if i can avoid it and when i went out
onto your balcony and looked
over whoo yeah i'm surprised at how many
people kind of get sketched out when
they like
like me they're like they don't want to
like lean over yeah
it kind of hits you like wow i'm looking
straight down oh man
i can remember when um i was a kid and
my dad was like okay we're gonna paint
the house this summer
and my dad was a carpenter so he he knew
what he was doing and he built houses
and he
you know and so we had this scaffolding
and it was
like three stories high this scaffolding
on this one side of the house
every and i was i was pretty young so i
i every time i'm in a
very high up situation i i always
remember
that scaffolding and it was you know and
i don't know if you've ever been on
scaffolding it's not
it's not like being on a balcony of a
well-built building
it sways in the wind and it's it moves
and it rickets and
and it's all tied together with like
these little clamp downs you know by
hand
um yeah i mean you know it's not that
sketchy but at the same time
like people fall off of it pretty
regularly so it's
so it sounds like it's kind of sketchy
it's sketchy yeah
it's a little bit sketchy i saw this
thing about
scaffolding sorry christian no no go you
hit it
so apparently in new york city the
scaffolding industry
is like a huge well some people say
racket some people say
business because apparently
buildings in new york so this i don't
know the date but
i think in like the 50s it was some lady
a brick fell off a building like the
siding of a building fell off and killed
a lady
and ever since then the city put in an
ordinance that says like
something crazy something crazy small
like every
like 15 years or so um i'm probably
saying this wrong but like there's a
crazy high turnaround for when you have
to reside your whole building you have
to get it inspected redone so the
scaffolding industry has become this
like
billion dollar industry and like there's
never not scaffolding in new york now
and it's a huge problem because it's
super like people hate it
people have to walk under it it's like a
huge health concern apparently
so it's just this whole thing and it's
just you would never think that
scaffolding is like
this huge controversial thing but
basically if you're it's like one more
expense of being a
business owner or a building owner in
new york is guess what every couple of
years you gotta
dude i can't pay the scaffolding mob i'm
not even imagining the money trying to
own a building
trying to own a building in manhattan
like i cannot even
the amount of the amount of nonsense you
would have to deal with on a daily basis
is beyond imagine like just imagine what
steve went through
when he had to when they came down
because there was that big fire in that
artist's building
in oakland that warehouse yeah yeah
and it killed a bunch of people and then
you know eventually the land they went
after the landlord because the
violations were so egregious like it was
it was it was a situation where the law
is saying how could you not
have done something um because nobody
else would have allowed it like how they
had it
and steve's the way that steve had the
building like back in the day
was you know a tiny version of that
in the sense that you know people had
built out
on like parts of the studios without
you know any sort of supervision or
professional contractors or
anything at all do you remember what
four looked like like yeah years ago it
was like a little
shanty town inside for the studio
oh sorry studio yeah there was like
literally sub buildings it felt like you
were in a little like japanese fishing
village or something because they had
like the japanese paper walls everywhere
like
yeah dividing it it was so odd it was
the sky
che that used to live out of there and
he had it subletted to
six different people at any
spencer was telling me this for for
studio five
they had over 20 different addresses
going to that studio oh my gosh
and i i still remember uh
like when when elections would come
around and they'd send out the mail-in
ballots like how many
mail-in ballots
dude it was like a all these different
names like
you could you could rig an election just
from that location
dude it was wild it was like the wild
west down there
and so anyways this building burned down
in uh oakland
and it was an artist building and then
the city of la obviously
you know started thinking oh well we
don't want that to happen to us we got
to do everything we can so they went
they went to
all the the residential art zoned
buildings that were the same zoning as
the one that burned down up north
and they just hammered the landlords now
imagine
that but in new york
it's like you know well that was the
stretch of steve coming in and he had to
put in like
five fire extinguishers at like every
entrance like he came in and just did
everything to make sure yeah that he
wasn't going to get sit in that seat and
that
his brickish
he had to go up against this guy that uh
yeah we put this out in the quarter crew
video
but steve was going on one day about
this guy who
he had to pass inspections through and
the guy was
we we started calling him a brick
because he was so
unrationally anti-brick building that
like there was no other word for this
guy just hates bricks
hate it when they're stacked up i see a
brick stacked up
we should show him our concrete jenga
video he'd like that oh yeah yeah yeah
that would be perfect we should get his
email from stevens
send it
we were saying like his daughter was
like killed in a brick action
his daughter was that lady in the 50s
new york exactly
maybe maybe that was his like great
grandmother no it's funny we studied
that case in law school
i remember that case that's a pretty
famous case yeah
about negligence and stuff interesting
but the same so
new york is full of this this stuff and
and we don't really think about it out
west
you know because like the the history of
how it was built is a little bit
different
but um for example the reason why
i think it's laguardia airport uh
doesn't have um subway access
is because of the taxi union in the
1970s
when laguardia was built they lobbied
against
the subway going to the to the airport
so all the subways end within like a
mile
of laguardia and then you have to take a
taxi
it's it's it's the most janky like
like reverse way of doing something
those unions man
they're powerful dude yeah and then i
could totally see the same thing going
down for the
for the uh scaffolding oh dude it's a
mob
i'm pretty sure it's something have you
ever seen you need some scaffolding
have you ever seen the other guys with
will ferrell and
and mark wahlberg and will will
ferrell's
on the case about a scaffolding
violation
i forgot that it's extremely relevant
man
oh that movie man that's what desk pop
is from right we use that all the time
a little hey swanson when was your last
desktop
uh september 08.
oh you haven't done it let me tell you
let me tell you something we honor the
flag and you crap all over it when you
don't do a desk pop
really guys guys i don't need to do a
desktop
oh my god it's so funny and then he does
it yeah after that everyone freaks out
like
that's a become a household term now
with like me and my gaming buddies
whatever if someone accidentally fires
their weapon in like pubg
or like whatever oh [ __ ] sorry i was
just that's yeah
we do the same thing yeah it's too
desperate it's so good man i watched
that movie like once a year
just just to stay fresh on the takes
will ferrell oh man i just rewatched
eastbound and down
and i forgot will ferrell's cameo in
that is like the weirdest thing
ever he's
he's just oh man that show is amazing
so funny so funny poor stevie man
most tragic character in television i
think stevie
yeah like no one gets the bottom side of
the boot like him
no yeah you know it's coming though
so at least you know that he will
yeah that uh that show and trailer park
boys
are i mean i think eastbound and down
has a little bit more like
known recognition but trailer park boyz
is
wendy wendy doesn't understand it i
think it's a masterpiece
dude that's the same with erica as well
she
there's you either like it or you don't
and like yeah
i feel like those who do it's like it
has the ability when you hear that
opening theme song to just like
calm you and like it just takes you away
to this place
for such a budget yeah it's insane the
atmosphere they're able to build
in that show right and the back stories
and the like the writing is cons the
writing is consistent
it's so consistent throughout through
the seasons and through the episodes
it's it's my gosh yeah yeah it's really
hard to make something
like that feel authentic like you're
actually
in in there like as if it's a you know
documentary
and it really feels like it with that
show some some like saskatchewan
or like alberta trailer park like in the
middle of
the country of canada it's so nova
scotia maybe i think
uh no nova scotia is on the east it's i
think it's set in saskatchewan
really okay yeah
who knows that's that's what a canadian
told me anyway
it's a it's a real gem that that intro
song is actually an old uh
honky tonk like country country in
western song
just sampled that that makes sense yeah
you could see that
it's it's really funny like seeing also
like how they like the
trailer park actually changes over the
years because they had to get different
sets
like eventually they like built their
own custom one but
dude those guys are oh man i they have
such a good thing going
to be able to just go out and make
something and just like goof around and
improv it a lot of it you know no
lighting
yeah zero lighting zero
lighting what not to worry about
anything else but the comedy did you
mean point the camera and hit record
because i
i heard you say something else i'm
pretty sure the director like at least
for the first seasons
is just the one rolling camera you know
and kind of just like yeah
like off the off the cuff directing so
it'd be interesting to get i think um
harley knows those guys it'd be
interesting to get them
um it is such a like the canadian
entertainment industry i've come to find
out is a very small world so he probably
knows them
he my friend keith actually uh knows
a guy who knows like them and stuff so
it's very small it's all everyone knows
each other but
yeah because it's a pretty small or it
used to be
a smaller industry obviously than
hollywood so those guys
really broke out you know in the comedy
genre there yeah now you have toronto
and vancouver that are
yeah i mean it's pretty pretty stephen
fleet
shooting the boys out in toronto
shooting season three
yeah yeah gotta have him back on the
front of the show
that was such a fun episode man yeah
yeah it was come back stephen
come on back yeah
but yeah so i mean back to the
you know what do we do when when people
people are out i mean
let me we cause we had to move around a
few videos
um you know to to to accommodate for
this
and that's the other thing that i wanted
to mention like being
ahead on your work
um is not something we always have but
like fortunately because we were kind of
we had a few videos that were either in
products in progress or were already
meat racked
um meat rack what do you mean by that
jake oh
can we not use that term i don't know so
we have we have a
we have a colloquial is that is that the
right word a colloquialism
yeah okay yeah we have one of those um
when we refer to any time
we have a video that's either in the can
or done
already um and it's just waiting to be
released we call it a meat rack video
because it's on the meat rack you know
you're saving it you're saving it for
winter
yeah the longer it's on the rack the
drier it gets it's true
sometimes it gets too dry and you gotta
throw it out
sometimes we have the crispier what it
gets yeah yeah the crispier
like yeah shavings crispy bits they get
too dry sometimes you know like the
bottom of the jerky bag when it's just
like oh i don't want that
yeah yeah it came from our winter break
right because
yep over the last two years we've made
sure that we still have some episodes
coming out over the winter break
whereas before we kind of just took our
vacation and let it go but
yeah right to make sure that we had some
react episodes come up we had to meet
rack some episodes early and that's just
that's where the term comes from so we
had that
and we we had uh well there's a special
note announcement on friday by the way
i don't think we should talk about that
let's save it for the video but
um this is just coming out the same day
so yeah same same day as this so
you probably have seen it on corridor
crew there's a big note announcement
so we had that and then also we had this
viral decade
video so what is the viral decade video
well
10 years ago roughly in in
march in like mid to late march uh sam
nico dropped the original
minecraft last mine cart video so
we said hey let's do a like
challenge where we make a bunch of
renders that are inspired by that and
then
you know it'll be this collection of of
challenge renders
and then we'll also sell them as nfts
and then we'll we'll drop the uh
minecraft video as well and it'll kind
of be this whole
like event type type piece and you know
through the course of some things like
happening with
some of the other videos you know the
insta360 video that we did a few weeks
back getting pushed around
then you know us having to accommodate
for the the phase two launch of the
website we had this thing in the can and
it was kind of floating around so
fortunately uh it it hit
this this virus hit at the same time
that we were getting ready to release
that so
thankfully dean is still functional
and nick you've been i mean surprisingly
very highly productive i think
throughout yeah i mean
this week i have but last week man i
mean this linus tech tips video that
came out well
today today is uh what wednesday yeah if
anyone's wondering that's when recording
this so this linus collab just dropped
today but
we actually were supposed to put that
out on sunday um last sunday so
but because that was my my edit and i
was like hit with this flu
and corona right it was just like ah
gosh and you know like
i was very i was kind of stressing about
it because it's like
it's not just a normal crew video
there's a whole other video being made
in canada by linus and his team
yeah and not to mention anthony like
slaving over this mac
like getting it working getting
everything to like the screen capture
which was like a huge thing like so
there's all this stuff going into it and
it's just like [ __ ]
now i went and got coronavirus and it's
like i have no energy now you done and
went and got to rhoda
i know so yeah i mean luckily we had the
flexibility and they were cool about it
but
yeah you know you do get more more and
more locked in
to the schedule that was
that was about the worst that we had to
change things around though
honestly because we had sort of other
things that were already prepped
um so that's that's i guess my second my
second tip
is like you know if you can just be a
little bit ahead on stuff
you know then you're you're you know you
combine that with having something
that's an infrastructure that's in place
plus being a little bit ahead and you
know you can you can spend a little bit
on the rainy days yeah and you can be
just prepared for these situations don't
take that for granted i do not take that
for granted because we
have never been ahead until like well
this year really so
yeah it's only because we've expanded
the team and you know
also you know i think the nature of our
schedule just
like i said it's it's a little bit more
locked than it used to be so
that can be a good thing because it gets
your head a little bit if you know hey
in three weeks i have to do this video
it's like
well i can shoot it now you know if we
have time
so that's a juice did you see
uh that linus and anthony like anthony
is linus's spencer
totally yeah did you see that i was so
jealous when i saw that guy i was like
they have a spencer
damn it man i mean if only we had a
spencer
i know did you should you say what what
what the context of that
of that curse is
i i mean we well we were trying to hire
spencer
but yeah you know um he ended up just
getting hired by stress level zero oh
that's what happened yeah
yeah that is what happened yes at least
he's still down the hall you know
totally yeah we can we can do this
where we all yell spencer at the same
time he'll show up he always shows up
i'm serious yeah that's the one thing
like i would have been heartbroken
had we not had that at least you know
um but given that we can still do the
spencer
call i feel you know i feel like it's
like that emergency button just in case
right you always have it right uh
dispenser signal in the sky
yeah i could probably do it right here
we should put one on the building
we should put a spencer's up spencer
light on the building oh my gosh dude
yes
what would it be what would the signal
would the the sign be
can we actually can we make a quarter
crew video about that a cool
s because okay so
so spencer spencer was living he was
living in san diego county
now he's obviously he's moving back up
um he's worked with brandon and stress
level zero for years so
it totally makes sense why you know he's
he's going that route and
that's he's gonna do like he's gonna
crush over there
but when when he moves back up we should
find out where he lives
and then uh put up a light
on top of the building and then see
see if we can actually come up with a
legitimate
spencer signal signal i think
if we could work something out with
stress level zero so we we could at
least have a beacon that illuminates
in their studio when we need you know
yeah yeah
something like that i think i think
that's a good video idea a beacon that
yeah i guess we could settle for a
beacon that illuminates it'd be way
cooler
if we went up to the roof though and a
fireman's pole
too that goes sideways well
you need some way to get spencer outside
to see the beacon so you need like
a light that says spencer go outside and
then you have the beacon
once he goes out there you know well if
he lives like christian maybe we can get
him to live next to you
oh then dude you'll see this you'll see
that spotlight if you put it up in the
sky for sure
because then we can yeah we can color it
a certain color
and then you know obviously the whole
like symbol
isn't actually that's a thing i don't
know if most people think about that but
like if you put the bat symbol
on a giant floodlight and then launched
at the sky it would just become
completely
diffused and totally obscured and you
wouldn't be able to see it at all
unless the actual scrim was like way far
away from the light source
oh yeah it's like right there and it was
hitting a cloud that was perfectly flat
on the bottom semantics yeah yeah
details
reality anyway if you guys want to see a
spencer signal let us know because
yes i personally would would really like
to make that
yeah um well at least he's still close
yeah yeah but anthony it definitely is
is the equivalent
of spencer and uh yeah props to him man
forgetting
i saw it in his eyes yeah they've got a
good team over there for sure
yeah they were a pleasure to work with
the whole process
and he's got all these sets and people
and they just casually built this
yeah yeah we'll build this level two mac
so yeah do we have to send that back and
they were already like a week
before us too they they got their videos
christian
dude i can't wait to play these games
dude i know sam's gonna be playing some
marathons
that's for sure now our computer when i
saw
oregon trail on there man jake when you
come back man
it's gonna be you and that computer when
you're here staying for a week man once
we all go home
yeah what jake's doing we're going to
trick him
he's going to oregon should i ford the
river
or should i [ __ ] the wagon and try to
float it across i don't know
i can't tell you what to do in your
oregon trail all you can do is guess
you know should i should i hunt should i
hunt
so often that all the animals go scarce
or should i press on
i don't know the only thing i know about
the oregon trail is you can get
gonorrhea
you can get gonorrhea yeah it's that's
like winning
they're not messing around like your
your whole family can do that no boss
and the final boss is gonna hear of the
donner party
that can happen to you that can happen
to you man we should oh my god we should
play as the donner party
and see what happens can you do that do
they give you like
like negative buffs maybe we can get
maybe we can get ltt anthony to
amend the game so that we can do that oh
man
it's probably open source at this point
we could probably probably do that
peter could probably code there you go
yeah
a resident game designer yeah has anyone
downloaded and played smush brethren yet
either here or from the audience oh no
not yet
okay that would be interesting or
interested to hear
how that works from the audience like if
it is functional
but there is a trailer that explains how
to download it
gotcha um but that's that's cool that we
put it out as we go
yeah i'm glad it actually like didn't
just die in that video
you know yeah um who's your favorite
character guys let us know
matt matt is my
you want to hear more of the slide
whistle uh it's in the the start
the start screen of the game i'm playing
the freaking
smush brother yeah that was so funny um
one thing uh we've been talking about
sam and nico and i
um is uh doing
is getting back to a few corridor videos
now
nice oh it's about time that's that's
what i've been freaking
craving yeah it's like doing anything in
production like that
yeah so those things are so much fun i
think as we
come out of this and you know now i mean
it's even easier now
we know that half the team well all the
teams pretty much
either had it or vaxxed so um so we can
kind of
you know get get jump back into a few of
this
uh a few of these ideas that we've been
holding on to so i'm super excited about
that even just today i was going through
and kind of compiling a short list of
of ideas that we've been holding on to
for
for the last you know year or two
um so in a minute man yeah and people
have been asking and honestly we've been
itching too it's just it was so hard
with
with um everything going on last year it
was really hard to get people together
to film for that kind of stuff
and you know we were just doing
everything we could to keep our head
above water with
every everything else yeah um
so podcaster oh [ __ ] come on matt
jordan's here oh hey jordan surprise
guest
i just yes jordan just interrupted yeah
she can't hear you but oh
yeah yeah yeah she chooses
just miming everything
um yeah so we'll be getting back into
the swing of that as the summer comes in
and i'm super excited for that um we'll
probably put a few more ideas on the
green light page
um you know for youtube like but just
you know things like uh locations
um you know special quarter crew
episodes that'll be kind of
like specifically tailored to those
productions stuff like that
um we'll be we'll be all part of it
so yeah man cool
it'll be fun to get back in the swing of
things just you know i guess
back to fully normal yeah we had to get
it on the tail end but hey yeah
then we'll be able to go right back to
normal the timing literally the timing
though is
literally ironic it's it's insane it's
like telling the last guy to get bit by
the zombie in the zombie movie
you know yeah dude they got the hub
everybody's like survival you got your
smartphone
some of the most tragic deaths of war
and and like other human atrocities are
when the thing is over
yeah but people are still dying because
one thing or another
like when i was doing all that civil war
studying
uh like there's there was this one boat
and they put all these uh union soldiers
on this boat and it was this
giant giant uh riverboat and
they were like yeah we're going home and
they had him like leave in richmond or
something
this thing's has a boiler explode
well there's like 2 500 people on this
boat
and like half of them died
imagine going through four years of
civil um the american civil war like pit
warfare people don't have shoes half
your friends are dying from freaking
diseases not even from the fighting
and then you get on this boat and you're
all elated to go home and then boom
boiler yeah
it happened a lot in world war one two
where like you know
after armistice was called like well
some people just didn't get the
the message you know yeah
it happens a lot have you heard of that
guy um well this happened
with a lot of japanese soldiers dan
carlin has a whole hardcore history on
it but there's this guy
um emoto i think oh yeah the guy who
held out
yeah he for like a crazy amount of time
he
he uh did not surrender
until 1976. crazy
what yeah that just goes to show you the
the
like mind state of the like in the
indoctrination that these soldiers
everyone on every side went through
you know americans japanese but it was
just like
hardcore nationalism man you should
listen to the hardcore history on it
because
yeah the the dan carlin like his
breakdown of it and
why that happened because it's not about
like okay
who was this guy it's it's it's the
whole thing is about how
did this happen how do you get to a
point where somebody's surrendering
31 years yeah after this
the end of a conflict and that's how he
opens
the east right he like starts with that
anecdote right to set up the whole thing
okay yeah yeah and and his the best
analogy for it is like
he keeps saying it throughout the
podcast like japanese culture was like
any other at the time
only more so yeah
and it's a it's a great analogy because
he ties he ties it into all these things
and it's
man it's fascinating um but he was he
was off on some like um
i think it was one of the islands of the
philippines um
actually and he was yeah and they
dropped a bunch of pamphlets over to
like try to tell him and
they even had people from the japanese
government go
and tell him that the war was over but
because he had only sworn
to his corporal or not his corporal like
his colonel or something
he had only sworn to this one guy i will
not come out until you tell me the war
is over
they had to drag this guy from wherever
he was living
in his old age to go tell this guy that
the war was over
and it was only then that he stopped
that he like laid down his arms oh geez
even he kept his rifle serviced i think
he's even like shot at people right
yeah people get wounded he killed people
oh my god
it's insane he killed like people and
they were like they were just locals i
think too
right just like kind of like going you
know walking down a path or whatever
i think people people would go and try
to find him
and and i think when they would do that
he would defend his territory
yeah that's what he was yeah right well
i mean imagine it from his perspective
that's an example
that's crazy yeah what does that call
cause i was just going through uh caught
in the
dance and that was really good i believe
supernova in the east
yeah really i like dan carlin i'm liking
his stuff
dude and he goes back to like into the
history of japan and stuff it's
really interesting if you want kind of
an overview of like how
the empire got to where well yeah it's
like four parts
it's four it's three or four parts such
a good podcast his uh
his breakdown of world war one was what
inspired me to
read uh on the civil war because it was
only after i listened to that and i felt
like i was there
you know because he goes into so much
detail over the course of like
25 hours or something and after
you get to the end of it and you feel
like you're not not like you were there
but you you know
so much and it's like it's visceral
and i wanted that experience again so
that's when i just got
into it that's when i go watch ken burns
the civil war
yeah kb classic oh yeah oh yeah
class it's hard for me to make it
through some of his stuff the vietnam
one
he did that one's hard to get through
bro it makes me feel sick to my stomach
uh you know some of this goes into yeah
that one man like obviously
like my our parents that's our parents
generation obviously and you know
my dad he didn't get drafted because he
had bad psoriasis
um but he that's the only reason why he
didn't is he was he didn't have a
college degree like he didn't
you know he was like a perfect candidate
um born in 1950 so
at the height of the war he was like 19.
um
and he had a ton of friends that went
like one of my one of my mom's
boyfriends
before she started dating my dad was
there and um
i didn't know much about it because no
no one really talked about it
but after i watched that and like i kind
of took the whole thing in i was like
whoa that
i can't believe we don't have more of a
like here is this huge event that
happened that significantly affects
everything that's still going on today
like you need to know about this because
it contextualizes so many different
things
um like i was i felt like i had been
you know it's like still buried in our
culture yeah you know like we still kind
of don't
yeah you see it pop up in movies every
once in a while but
uh the scale of like slaughter was
pretty
pretty insane slaughter that was hey we
know they're out there somewhere so go
walk around in the woods until they fire
at you
and that's how you'll find him on him
your point man dies that's how you find
the enemy
take that hill and then give it up again
and then take it again and give it up
again and hey don't go into cambodia
because we can't
um even though all of their arms and
munitions are going up and down
the ho chi minh trail it's okay don't
worry about it
uh yeah um so anyways um
not to get into the politics of that but
now we know why the hippies were
right but that that context that was the
first time where people like had a
adverse of a strongly adverse
like reaction to a type of like
you know international engagement that
the united states was the forefront
player in and obviously that now carries
into today like
so it's you know oh yeah it's crazy
everyone should know about it everyone
should watch that documentary at least
definitely it's so well presented ken
burns yeah i mean there's a reason why
there's a whole
official named after him basically yeah
he's a pioneer man
did you also know that he's a man of
quilts
a man of quilts yeah yeah ken burns has
uh uh extensive
quilt collection wow yeah
yeah it's it's a weird it's a weird
thing but um
i mean yeah i've heard of weirder
collections before so you know
if uh because you get to make the quilts
you got to choose the fabric i don't
think he makes them
he he buys them oh no okay yes because
you know being a documentarian it's
almost like making a quilt you know you
get all these
different i think that's why he likes
him i think that's why he likes him
because
he buys them and they they represent all
these different areas of history and all
these different cultures
because that's cool that's what people
do when they make a quilt they put their
culture into it
yeah it's pretty it's just scraps like
you know
making something out of scraps so that's
kind of cool yeah it's the coolest [ __ ]
ever
hey everyone has the weird hobby weird
collection you know
yeah yeah i don't think you'd know
anything about that nick
nothing no just ignore everything
behind me you're calling it all
are those the coins i got some coins
back there yeah i got some coins
let's see let's see which coin i got
some coins back there
show us your coins
sick what is that it's a dope one
wait can i guess before you tell me can
i guess after base just based on what
you've taught me
sure oh wow it's a cystertius
okay it's obviously roman
it's late roman what is that
ish i can't i can't re i can't read the
year on it
yeah i'm trying to uh this one i'm not
sure of the year because the
inscription's pretty
pretty messed up but see this little uh
i think that's victory probably there
and then you have an sc
okay i believe it stands for just the
roman state
um i think it's like security
civilis or something is what it i
believe it stands for don't quote me on
that
um but as far as that found
good question man i bought that one on
uh on online
so i didn't like clean that one or
anything oh god i have had some time to
get back into it
with coronavirus like this week i was
just like man maybe i'll
clean a coin or two just stop some of
these old coins
aren't they worth more though and you
don't clean them all the way
well you got to clean them you got to
get the dirt off but not the patina
because you know you don't want to strip
them down to the bare metal because then
it's like
you could have made that any day you
know the age is what
makes it obviously valuable so but you
want to be able to read it
so you got to get the dirt off yeah yeah
it's you want to just like take the dirt
off
and not like strip it down to the metal
so it's hard though
it takes a lot of patience so i seldom
have time to do it anymore
that's why i just buy them sometimes
because
i don't know it's it's like a fun little
hobby to dive into
it's real man you're touching history
dude for sure you're touching
history in a major way and like people
made this
they they were the first like form of
art that was widely circulated
the first form of almost social media
you know
if you think about it with this
coin this guy is i think it's maxentius
i don't know this is
yeah i think it's mexenius but he's
basically saying
check it out here's a selfie of me i'm
the [ __ ]
right so and this gets broadcast all
over the empire it was almost the only
form of communication that an emperor
you know besides maybe like you know
sending out announcements to the town
crier i mean this was what people were
using every day
so imagining the hands that this went
through and like what the
you know yeah what was what was that
going on
yeah it's crazy man so that's why he
likes that coin gut
right probably like they just physically
go thumbs up
and then collect it and then yeah it's
pretty fun to like be
when you do clean them off you're the
first person to see that
since it was probably you know dropped
in the mud
by some roman or provincial or whoever
the hell you know like
this guy i just cleaned the other day i
don't know if you can see him
and it's really hard to see him but he's
kind of a
motley guy i'm going to do a video with
daniel on this on the website so i'll
get more into the coins soon i'll even
clean a couple for you guys
um jake when you're in town if you want
to if anyone else wants to clean them i
got a bunch so i could give you guys a
little lesson
whiskey and coin cleaning sounds fun
crew cut season two there you go cool
um cool well yeah let's definitely do
that i'm actually i'm planning on coming
into town
at the end of the month maybe early may
yeah so okay yeah i'll see you guys in a
little bit
sweet sweet man you know we're going to
get a quick cut
speaking of crew cuts you know who has
had trouble
with this whole like week where everyone
is out is daniel
because his content relies solely
on us being in the office so yeah today
he was like he went up to me
today he went up to me asking like if i
could do like if we could just like
anybody else
like he's just like can i film something
with you looking for scraps
looking for any scraps he can you know
conjure up um
i think hopefully he has a backlog of
footage but yeah i can imagine
he's sitting there like what do i do
yeah exactly
dude it's funny because he he may have
dodged the virus because of how
consistently
he is working daniel's still working
daniel's it's like i'm sad that didn't
make it into the smush brethren game i
know
some of the funniest jokes in that video
were like daniel's still working
yesterday the 24 7 live stream of daniel
reporter as you play just working yeah
i respect it i respect the scene with
the desk in the background
there's only a couple of us that don't
play so and it's kind of like the
catchphrase if anybody's slacking off
he's like hey
daniel's over there still working yeah
yeah
this is my homage to daniel
as i play us out here
slide whistle whistle sorry do you need
slime yes we need slide whistle because
my mouth is too dry to get a
tone help us out matt come on now other
people ask for
a little more slide whistle if you see a
man
out there working it's probably daniel
just know that there you go if you see a
wren
out there working he's probably getting
filmed by daniel
again again he's working right now
working at the beach working in the
field
working in them content fields
all right thanks for watching everybody
it was beautiful